[MUSIC PLAYING]
RAZIEL ALVAREZ: Hi, everyone.
My name is Raziel.
I'm an engineering lead
in TensorFlow Lite.
And today I will be
covering a lot of the work
that the team has done
over the past year
to bring your
features that you can
take advantage of right away.
Hopefully you're
already doing that.
I will also cover
a lot of the work
that we have for this year.
But before we jump
into that, let
me give you a brief introduction
of what TensorFlow Lite is.
So TensorFlow Lite is our
infrastructure framework
to run machine
learning on device.
And the reason why we decided
to build TensorFlow Lite was
because machine
learning, you typically
think of it as running
on the server, right?
But more and more is
moving to edge devices,
like mobile devices, cars,
wearables, you name it.
So there is more
machine learning moving
to different kinds of devices.
And there is good
reasons for that.
One, you have access
to a lot more data.
Because you have access to the
audio, to the camera, and you
don't have to stream it
all the way to the server.
So you can do a lot of stuff.
You can do a [INAUDIBLE].
And that means that
you can build faster
and close-knit interactions.
Another advantage of running
machine learning on devices
is that it has a strong
privacy-preserving component,
right?
Because the data
stays on device.
It doesn't necessarily
has to go onto the server.
However, well, that means that
basically by building machine
learning on device
by allowing that,
we can build products
that otherwise wouldn't
be able really to work
if you really rely only
on server-side execution.
However, it is hard.
Perhaps one obvious
thing is that you
don't have the same
compute power that you
have in the server, right?
So if you have a new, very cool
shiny machine learning model
that consumes too
much compute power,
it's not like in
the server that you
can throw perhaps more servers
at it and be done with it.
You have to be mindful
of the resources
that you have in the device.
Another of those
resources is the memory.
So you have restricted memory.
So you have to be careful
about how you craft your model.
Perhaps try some
compression techniques.
And last but not least,
many of these devices
are battery powered, right?
So even if you have
a model that fits
in memory that can
execute, well, you
don't want to consume
all the battery
in a battery-powered device.
So for all these reasons, that's
why we build TensorFlow Lite.
We want to make deploying
machine learning on Edge
devices as easily as possible.
And what can you do
with it right now?
Well, you can do
a lot of things.
These are different
tasks that are supported
by TensorFlow Lite already.
And if you look at it, when
you hear machine learning,
you typically fall into
one of these tasks--
text, speech, image
processing, audio processing,
a lot of content generation.
So really everything
is already there
for you to take advantage of.
And because we are ready
are able to support
all these tasks, it means that
it has a lot of users already.
So TensorFlow Lite
is currently deployed
in over two billion
devices in production.
And this normally means Google
properties, and some of which
are really core to Google, like
the Assistant, Google Photos--
those from other companies, from
other large companies and also
frameworks.
So a lot of our infrastructure
is powering frameworks
like AutoML and ML Kit.
And I can tell you many
reasons why it's a good idea
to use our infrastructure.
But we saw that it will
be best if we bring
two of our important
clients to tell you
how they use TensorFlow Lite
and why they decided to use it.
Our first presenter is Alex.
He's coming from the
Google Assistant.
And the Google Assistant, I
mean it has a wide variety
of devices where it's running.
So let's hear from him why
they're using TensorFlow Lite
and how they are doing.
[APPLAUSE]
ALEX GRUENSTEIN: Thanks, Raziel.
So I'm Alex.
I'm the engineering lead on
our embedded speech recognition
team at Google.
So one of the key applications
for speech recognition
at Google is the
Google Assistant.
Google recently announced
that the Google Assistant
is on about a billion devices,
ranging from phones, speakers,
smart displays, cars,
TVs laptops, wearables,
you name it.
We're trying to put
the Assistant into it.
From my perspective, that
means a wide range of devices--
high-end devices, low-end
devices, ARM, x86,
battery-powered,
plugged in, a wide range
of operating systems.
So basically the neural
nets that I build have
to be able to run anywhere.
For Assistant, we have a
couple of key speech on-device
capabilities.
The first is the hotword.
You need to be able to say, hey,
Google, to trigger your device.
We need to both
detect that hotword,
and we need to
recognize that it's
your voice and not somebody else
trying to activate your phone.
This means because this
is running all the time,
we have to have a tiny
memory and computation
footprint running continuously.
And we're extremely
latency sensitive.
As soon as you say the hotword,
we need to immediately trigger.
Our other major application is
on-device speech recognition.
We use this often
when you're offline
or you have a bad
network connection.
So instead of using
the server, we actually
run speech recognition
on the device.
Now this is kind of on the
other end of the spectrum.
Here we're trying to run large
models as fast as possible
to get the best
possible accuracy.
So it's a high
computational load,
typically running
in a short burst.
Over the years,
we've been working
on this for a long time.
Before there was TensorFlow
Lite, before the rest
TensorFlow--
so we've been investing
a lot for a long time
in building our own on-device
neural net libraries
and shipping them to
production in Google
products for a long time.
As a team, we've already
invested significantly
in keeping our code size
tiny, our memory usage small,
optimizing our compute for all
of these different platforms.
And all of our code, after
many years of production use,
is really hardened and hopefully
is bug free as you can get it.
But over the last year, we
decided to migrate to TFLite.
Now this wasn't an
easy decision for us
because our libraries are
already so well optimized.
And as we switched over,
we checked very carefully
to make sure that TFLite
would meet or beat
our existing libraries in
terms of their size and speed.
And I'm happy to report
that over the last year,
we've migrated all of the
computation we do on CPU
for our models to TFLite.
Now we're excited about
this, because this really
lays the groundwork for us
moving to a new standard that's
being widely adopted.
And we think TFLite will help us
accelerate our models on things
like GPUs and Edge TPUs, all
the new kinds of accelerators
that are coming.
So thanks.
I'll turn it back
over to Raziel.
[APPLAUSE]
RAZIEL ALVAREZ: Thanks, Alex.
So Alex highlights two key
goals for TensorFlow Lite.
So we want to be able to
support your current use cases.
But perhaps equally
important and more important
is we want to
cater to your needs
that you will have in one,
two years in the future.
So our next presenter
is Huejie from NetEase.
NetEase is a
China-based company that
has several applications and
hundreds of millions of users.
So let's welcome him.
[APPLAUSE]
HUIJIE LIN: Thanks, Raziel.
I'm Huijie Lin from
NetEase Youdao.
And in Youdao, we are
first the leading company
in online education as well.
And we have built a lot
of dictionary translation
and note-taking
applications in China.
We have over 800
million users in total.
And we also have 22
million daily active users.
In the past years, we have built
several dictionary translation
and note-taking applications.
For example, we have the most
popular dictionary application
in China, which is
Youdao Dictionary.
And we also have the most
popular translation application
in China, which is
Youdao Translator.
And we also have the most
popular dictionary and language
learning application in
India, which is U-Dictionary.
And in these applications, we
provide some features for users
to conveniently look up
words in the scenarios.
Such as for example,
you can use your camera
to recognize the words
in from the images
and do the OCR and the
translation on your devices.
So we use the TensorFlow
Lite to accelerate the OCR
and translation here.
And also, we have provided
the photo translation
in our applications.
For example, you
can use the camera
to take a photo from
the many scenarios.
And it will do the
whole image OCR
and translate the text
into another languages.
And then it will erase
the text on the image
and replace the original text
to the translated text and then
to present users with
the translations.
And in this scenario, we
also use the TensorFlow Lite
to accelerate our OCR and the
translation services here.
And we all know that the
OCR and the translation,
it is very sensitive to
the binary size and also
computation resources
and its responding time.
So we choose the TensorFlow
Lite to accelerate our abilities
on device to provide the more
efficient on-device [INAUDIBLE]
here.
So that's why we choose the
TensorFlow Lite to do this.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
RAZIEL ALVAREZ: Thanks, Huijie.
It's really excited to see
how our infrastructure is
used by hundreds of millions
of users around the world.
And this is something that
I wanted to highlight.
Just like the rest
of TensorFlow,
TensorFlow Lite is geared
to not only towards Google
but towards everybody out there.
Everybody should be able
to take advantage of it.
OK, so for the rest
of the presentation,
I will cover what I
said at the start.
A lot of the features that
are having made available
over the past year and some
of our roadmap for this year.
In the product, we
organize our engineering
in four main themes.
The first one is usability.
Overall, it means we want
to be able to get you up
and running and easily
and fast as possible.
Now, once you have your
model, basically we
want to get you executing
that model as fast as possible
in the hardware
that you care about.
Then with optimization,
we look at how
certain things that we
can do to your model
to make it even
faster and smaller.
And finally, with all our
documentation efforts,
we want to give you
all the resources
that you need so you can get the
most out of our infrastructure.
So let's start with usability.
There is different ways
of getting up and running
in TensorFlow Lite.
But at the end of the
day, you most likely
will end up wanting
at some point
to train the model in
TensorFlow and convert it
to TensorFlow Lite.
Flow is logically
very simple, right?
You train in TensorFlow.
You get a saved model.
Then you use a TensorFlow
Lite converter.
And then you get a
TensorFlow Lite model
that you can now execute on
different kinds of devices.
However, there is some
points of failure.
TensorFlow Lite, we
made the decision
to take a subset of TensorFlow
ops and optimize those.
And that means that
basically we don't
have all the same hundreds of
operations that TensorFlow has.
The other reason
is some semantics,
we don't support Git
on TensorFlow Lite,
like control flow,
which is typically used
for recurrent neural networks.
But we've made already strides
trying to basically make
this easier and better for you.
So last year, we launched
TensorFlow Select.
And this basically
means that you
can execute TensorFlow
ops in TensorFlow Lite.
In the pipeline, we're
making improvements
to TensorFlow Select by
enabling selective registration.
And I will explain what all this
means in the following slides.
And we're also working on
adding control flow support.
OK, so select, like
I said, it means
you can execute TensorFlow
Ops in TensorFlow Lite.
It comes at the cost of
some binary size increase
because right now, it's
basically all or nothing.
But that's why we're building
selective registration.
Selective registration
is already something
that you can take
advantage on TensorFlow
Lite for our building ops.
So you only include
in the binary
the ops that you
are really using.
So you don't end up increasing
your binary size unnecessarily.
So we're bringing that
to TensorFlow Select.
And we are also trying
to blur the line of what
the TensorFlow ops and the
TensorFlow Lite ops are.
And one of the
key points of this
is blur the performance
gap that there might
be between one and the other.
Now control flow, again,
where it's something
that we are working on.
And this is one of the
fairly larger pain points
where you're trying to convert
recurrent neural network
to TensorFlow Lite.
So this is something
that is in progress.
So we are rallying support
for loops and conditionals.
And all this is part
of a bigger effort
to basically to revamp
entirely our converter.
And we took your
feedback very seriously.
And we want these converter to
answer these three questions,
right?
If something fails, what went
wrong, where it went wrong,
and what can you do to fix it?
OK, so jumping to the
next theme is performance.
We want your models to
execute as fast as possible
in the hardware that
you have available.
And if you saw in
[INAUDIBLE] slide,
we've made huge strides
in this area, right?
So this an example
of a MobileNet V1.
The execution in
CPU floating point
compared to the
quantized version in CPU.
And now with the recently
developer preview
that we launched for
our CPU, GPU delegate,
we get huge gains, like
over 7x improvements.
And then by using the
Edge TPU delegate,
we get crazy speed-ups, 62x.
So again, this is an area where
we're working really hard.
Again, some things that
are really available, we
have a very nice benchmark
and profiling tool.
And we have a few delegates.
For those of you who are not
familiar with the concept
of TensorFlow Lite
delegates, basically it's
our abstraction layer
that allows securing
models [INAUDIBLE] the CPU.
So right now, we have
these three delegates,
like Edge TPU, GPU, and the
neural network API delegate.
And in the pipeline,
we are working also
on CPU improvements because
we know that CPU is important.
I'm not listing here, in
the pipeline, anything
around newer delegates because
it tends to be a partner
issue with other companies.
And I don't have
anything to announce yet.
But we are working on that.
OK, our benchmarking tool
is basically a profiler.
We added some features to it.
It supports multithreading.
You can see statistics
per execution.
And it supports the
neural network API.
So when you execute
the profiler,
you get a lot of information.
This is just a snippet of
all the stuff that you get.
So in this case,
we're showing you here
information pair on each one
of the ops in your graph,
how long it took to execute.
Then you also get a nice
summary of all the op
times in your graph and
many useful statistics.
So you can decide
maybe there is a way
that you can change one
out for an other type that
is more efficient or tweak
your graph in some way.
OK, now let's talk
about the delegate.
So like I said, the delegate
is our abstraction layer
for executing graphs
in different hardware.
And the way it
works is very nice
because basically in
the TensorFlow Lite,
you prepare a model, right?
You are not necessarily
saying this model
is for this hardware.
You just prepare your model.
And then the interpreter
will take it.
And then for those
delegates that you register,
it will go, each one by one.
And they will say, OK, how much
of this graph can you execute?
And what the delegate
is going to execute,
they will be executed in CPU.
So by doing these, basically you
will always be able to execute.
And if anything, you will
get better performance
if the delegate can
consume more of your graph.
So we have already
an Edge TPU delegate.
Edge TPUs are Google's
ML hardware accelerator
for the Edge.
It's very high performance.
It's also very small.
And it has a small
power footprint.
And later on, we'll have more
information about the Edge TPUs
in a very cool demo.
The next delegate
is the GPU delegate.
These are developer
preview right now.
And we see very nice performance
improvements, 2x to 7x
compared to floating
point in CPU
at the cost of our relatively
small binary size increase.
And how do you enable
the GPU delegate?
Well, just like
any other delegate,
this is an example of
the interpreter and just
executing one inference.
And the only thing
that you need to do
to enable, in this
case, the GPU delegate,
you just instantiate it and
pass it to the interpreter.
And that's it.
So stuff that we're working
on for the GPU delegate, well,
we want to add more ops.
Right now, most of the
ops in the GPU delegate
are covering
convolutional networks.
But obviously, we want to cover
recurrent neural networks,
for example.
We want to improve
performance even further.
And we want to finalize the API.
So this is generally available,
not just a developer preview.
The final delegate that
I wanted to mention
is the Android
neural network API.
So this will allow you to
execute any other hardware
that the Android
NN API supports.
So it should be just
transparent for you.
Finally, CPU is still very
important for many use cases.
Most devices have
some form of a CPU.
So we are targeting
further improvements
on ARM and x86 architectures.
OK, so the next theme
is optimization.
So in the performance
theme, we took a model,
and we called it in a way
that can execute very fast.
But maybe we can do
tweaks to your model
to make it even faster
or even smaller.
So we already did
some work here.
So last year, we released this
post-training quantization tool
that it gives very
nice performance
improvements on CPU.
And this is the
first launch that we
have in what we are calling
a model optimization toolkit.
So more techniques will
be part of this toolkit
and available for
use for everybody.
And in the pipeline, some
of these new techniques
that we are going to
put in the toolkit
is more quantization work.
In these cases, what we call
fixed-point quantization,
which gives you further
improvements and CPU
and allows you to
execute in more hardware.
Because a lot of the
specialized hardware,
like neural processing units,
are use fixed point base.
There is no floating
point support.
We're also excited because
we're working on a new technique
called connection pruning.
And I will cover a little
bit of all these things next.
So quantization
means just changing
the precision of
your model and how
it's executed on the device.
We launched our post-training
quantization tool
where basically, you
take your saved model.
And when you convert it
to TensorFlow Lite format,
you can just turn on a flag.
And it will be quantized.
And because it's
on CPU, basically
we can do a mix of fixed
point and floating point math,
try to get the most
performance and relatively
small accuracy loss.
And we see very nice
improvements this way.
If the model gets
fully quantized
and you get 4x compression,
and for convolutional models,
we see 10% to 50%
performance improvement.
But for fully connected
RNNs, we see up to 3x.
So again, this is something
that is extremely simple to try.
If you already are using
TensorFlow Lite or plan to use
it, just give this a try.
Obviously you have to validate
how the accuracy is affected
in your particular model.
But so far, we've seen
very good numbers.
And many of the two billion
devices that we mentioned
before are running this way.
In the pipeline, again, we're
making further improvements
in the quantization
approaches that we have.
So we're working on this
fixed point quantization.
And we want to make it
more powerful by enabling
quantized training and
also very easy to use.
And that's why we're also
bringing more post-training
quantization support.
So this is an example
of Keras model.
It's very easy.
You have used two dense layers.
And now let's say that you
want to train with quantization
those two dense layers.
Well, soon enough, you will be
able to just import to our API
and just say, quantize
those two layers.
And the post-training
quantization
will, just like for
fixed point, will
work very much like the one
that we already support,
where you have the
conversion path.
And the only thing that
you need to pass extra
is some calibration data.
And calibration data is
just the typical data
that your model
sees as the input.
So for example, if you have
an input, an image processing
model, you just need
to pass some images.
And you don't really need
to pass a ton of images.
So in preliminary numbers,
for example, for MobileNets,
we see with 25 images,
we do very well.
These are some of the numbers--
again, preliminary numbers
that we see with this tool.
We have the float baseline.
And then if you do
quantized training,
then you get almost
the same accuracy
with all the benefits
of quantization,
of compression and
fast execution.
And then even further,
if you really--
for some reason, you don't want
to invest i quantized training,
or perhaps you just have a model
that you got somewhere, you
can still quantize it with
post-training quantization.
And you see there that
basically the accuracy
is almost the same.
The other technique that we
are heavily investing right now
is connection pruning.
What this means is
that at training time,
we just prune connections
in the network.
The pruned connections
becomes [INAUDIBLE]..
And that creates
just a sparse tensor.
The nice benefits
of sparse tensors
is that you can compress them
because you can skip the zeros.
And you can create
potentially faster models
if you have less
computations to do.
So coming very
soon, we are going
to add a training time pruning,
again, as a Keras-based API.
And in the pipeline,
we are working
on first-class support of sparse
execution in TensorFlow Lite.
So again, in our
example from Keras,
this has your two dense layers.
You want to prune connections
from those two layers.
And then the only thing that you
need to do is just hit Prune.
So it's very, very simple.
At that point, when you compare
the model to TensorFlow Lite
format, basically by using
just even zipping the file,
you will get a nice compression.
And these are some, again,
very preliminary numbers.
In this case, a MobileNet
which are actually
pretty hard to prune compared
to other perhaps larger models.
But we see a very small
loss of 50% and even 75%.
Finally, documentation--
well, again, we
want to give you
all the resources
that you need to get the
most out of TensorFlow Lite.
And we have already done
really nice improvements.
We have a new site that
is not only just pretty,
but it has more content.
We currently have
a model repository
with five models and
applications that you can try.
But we want to work, and we
are working on more tutorials.
And we're also trying to
expand our repository.
So this is how
the new site looks
if you haven't taken a look.
The goal is, again, not
only that it's pretty,
but it answers your questions.
So please give us
some more feedback
if there is things that
are still lacking there.
Yeah, so we revamped
our documentation.
And very important, we
also have there the roadmap
for the foreseeable future.
So a lot of the stuff that
I'm talking about now,
you can see it there and
in more detail perhaps.
And then again, we
have a repository
with all these
applications and tutorials.
And we are expanding it.
We want to make the
repository into something
that if you don't want to go--
or before you start
trying to train something,
perhaps we already have a
model that you can reuse.
By the way, TensorFlow
Mobile is deprecated,
especially with the
work that we need
to bring TensorFlow
Select, which
allows you to execute TensorFlow
ops in TensorFlow Lite.
There is no need for
TensorFlow Mobile except if you
are doing training on-device.
So that is the reason why
we're keeping that there.
But yeah, training.
So if you see, we're building a
lot of the basic infrastructure
that you will need when you are
trying to prepare a training
pipeline to execute on-device.
I don't have anything
to announce now.
But I just wanted to let you
know that we are working on it
and thinking a lot about it.
What about TensorFlow 2.0?
Well, it should work.
If you have a saved
model, you should
be able to convert it
to TensorFlow Lite.
And before we go,
two last things.
One is there was a lot
of content in this talk.
Tomorrow we have some
breakout sessions
where we're going to cover
TensorFlow Lite in general
and optimization in particular.
And also I want to
introduce Pete Warden, who
is going to talk about
some very cool project.
PETE WARDEN: Awesome.
[APPLAUSE]
So thanks so much, Raziel.
And I'm really
excited to be here
to talk about a new project
that I think is pretty cool.
So TensorFlow Lite
for microcontrollers.
What's that all about?
So this all comes back to when
I actually first joined Google
back in 2014.
And as you can imagine,
there were a whole bunch
of internal projects
that I didn't actually
know about as a member
of the public that
sort of blew my mind.
But one in particular came about
when I actually spoke to Raziel
for the first time.
And he explained.
And he was on the speech
team at the time working
with Alex, who you just saw.
And he explained that
they use network models
of only 13 kilobytes in size.
At that time, I only really had
experience with image networks.
And the very smallest of them
was still multiple megabytes.
So this idea of having
a 13 kilobyte model
was just amazing for me.
And what amazed me
even more was when
he told me why these
models had to be so small.
They were running
them-- they needed
to run them on these DSPs
and other embedded chips
in smartphones.
So Android could listen out
for wake words like, hey,
Google, while the main
CPU was powered off
to save the battery.
These microcontrollers
often only
had tens of kilobytes of
RAM and flash storage.
So they simply couldn't
fit anything larger.
They also couldn't rely
on cloud connectivity
because the amount of power that
would have been drained just
keeping a radio connection
alive to send data over
would have just
been prohibitive.
So that really struck
me, that conversation
and the continued work that
we did with the speech team,
because they had
so much experience
doing all sorts of different
approaches with speech.
They'd spent a lot of time and
a lot of energy experimenting.
And even within the
tough constraints
of these embedded
devices, neural networks
were better than any of the
traditional methods they used.
So I was left
wondering if they'd
be really useful for other
embedded sensor applications
as well.
And it left me really wanting
to see if we could actually
build support for
these kind of devices
into TensorFlow itself so that
more people could actually
get access.
At the time, only people
in the speech community
really knew about the
groundbreaking work
that was being done.
So I really wanted to
share it a lot more widely.
So today, I am
pleased to announce
that we are releasing the
first experimental support
for embedded platforms
in TensorFlow Lite.
And to show you
what I mean, here
is a demonstration board that
I actually have in my pocket.
And this is a prototype
of a development
board built by SparkFun.
And it has a Cortex-M4 processor
with 384 kilobytes of RAM
and a whole megabyte
of flash storage.
And it was built by Ambiq
to be extremely low power,
drawing less than one
milliwatt in a lot of cases.
So it's able to run on a
single coin battery like this
for many days, potentially.
And I'm actually going to
take my life in my hands
now by trying a live demo.
[LAUGHS]
So let us see if
this is actually--
it's going to be
extremely hard to see,
unless we dim the lights.
There we go.
So what I'm going
to be doing here
is by saying a particular word
and see if it actually lights
up the little yellow light.
You can see the blue
LED is flashing.
That's just telling me that
it's running [INAUDIBLE]..
So if I try saying,
yes, yes, yes.
I knew I was taking my
life into my hands here.
Yes.
There we go.
[LAUGHS]
[APPLAUSE]
So I'm going to quickly move
that out of the spotlight.
So as you can see, it's
still far from perfect.
But it is managing to do
a job of recognizing when
I say the word and not
lighting up when there's
unrelated conversations.
So why is this useful?
Well, first this is
running entirely locally
on the embedded chip.
So we don't need to have
any internet connection.
So it's a good useful first
component of a voice interface
system.
And the model itself
isn't quite 13 kilobytes.
But it is down to 20 kilobytes.
So it only takes up 20
kilobytes of flash storage
on this device.
And the footprint of
the TensorFlow Lite
code for microcontrollers is
only another 25 kilobytes.
And it only needs about
30 kilobytes of RAM
available to operate.
So it's within the
capabilities of a lot
of different embedded devices.
Secondly, this is
all open source.
So you can actually
grab the code yourself
and build it yourself.
And you can modify.
I'm showing you here on
this particular platform.
But it actually works
on a whole bunch
of different embedded chips.
And we really want to
see lots more supported.
So we're keen to work
with the community
on collaborating to get
more devices supported.
You can also train
your own model.
Just something that recognizes
yes isn't all that useful.
But the key thing is that
this comes with a tutorial
that you can use to actually
train your own models.
And it also comes
with a data set
of 100,000 utterances
of about 20 common words
that you use as
your training set.
And that first link
there, the AIY Projects
one, if you could
actually go to that link
and contribute your voice
to the open data set,
it should actually
increase the size
and the quality of the data
set that we can actually
make available.
So that would be awesome.
And you can actually
use the same approach
to do a lot of different
audio recognition
to recognize different
kinds of sounds
and even start to use it for
similar signal processing
problems, things like
predictive maintenance.
So how can you try
this out for yourself?
If you're in the audience
here, at the end of today,
you will find that
you get a gift box,
and you actually have
one of these in there.
[APPLAUSE]
And all you should need to
do is remove the little tab
between the battery.
And it should
automatically boot up
preflashed with
this yes example.
[LAUGHTER]
So you can try it
out for yourself.
And let me know how it goes.
Just say, yes, the
TensorFlow I liked, is the--
and we also include
all the cables.
So you should be able to
just program it yourself
through the serial port.
Now these are the first
700 boards ever built.
So there is a wiring issue.
So it will drain the battery.
It would last more
like hours than days.
But that will actually--
knock on wood-- be fixed in the
final product that's shipping.
And you should be
able to develop
with these in the
exact same way that you
will with the final
shipping product.
And if you're
watching at home, you
could preorder one of
these from SparkFun
right now for, I
think, it's $15.
And you'll also find lots
of other instructions
for other platforms
in the documentation.
So we are trying to
support all of the--
or as many of the
modern microcontrollers
that are out there that
people are using as possible.
And we welcome
collaboration with everybody
across the community to help
unlock all of the creativity
that I know is out there.
And I'm really
hoping that I'm going
to be spending a lot of my
time over the next few months
reviewing pull requests.
And finally, this was my
first hardware project.
So I needed a lot of
help from a lot of people
to actually help bring
this prototype together,
including the TFLite team,
especially Raziel, Rocky, Dan,
Tim, and Andy.
Alasdair, Nathan, Owen, and Jim
at SparkFun were lifesavers.
We literally got these in
our hands middle of the day
yesterday.
So the fact that they
managed to pull it together
is a massive tribute.
And also Scott, Steve,
Arpit, and Andre
at Ambiq, who actually designed
this process and helped us
get the software going.
And actually, a lot of people
at Arm as well, including a big
shout out to Neil and Zach.
So this is still a
very early experiment.
But I really can't wait to see
what people build with this.
And one final note, I will
be around to talk about MCUs
with anybody who's interested
at the breakout session on day
two.
So I'm really looking forward
to chatting to everyone.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
RAZIEL ALVAREZ: Thanks, Pete.
We really hope
that you try this.
It's the early stages.
But you see the huge effort
just to make this happen.
We think that it will be
really impactful for everybody.
Now before we go
again, and I promise
is the last thing
you hear from me,
I want to welcome June,
who's going to talk about how
by using TensorFlow Lite,
with the Edge TPU delegate,
are able to train these
teachable machines.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
JUNE TATE-GANS: Thanks, Raziel.
Hi, my name is June Tate-Gans.
I'm actually one of the lead
software engineers inside
of Google's new Coral group.
And I've been asked to
give a talk about the Edge
TPU-based teachable
machine demo.
So first, I should
tell you what Coral is.
Coral is a platform for products
with on-device machine learning
using TensorFlow and TFLite.
Our first two products are
a single-board computer
and a USB stack.
So what is the Edge TPU?
It's a Google-designed ASIC that
accelerates inference directly
on the device that
it's embedded in.
Its very fast, localizes data
to the edge rather than cloud,
doesn't require a network
connection to run,
and this allows for a whole
new range of applications
of machine learning.
So the first product we
built is the Coral Dev Board.
This is a single-board
computer with a removable SOM.
It runs Linux and Android.
And the SOM itself has a
gigabyte of RAM, a quad core
A53 SoC, Wi-Fi and Bluetooth,
and of course, the Edge TPU.
Now the second is our
Coral Accelerator board.
Now this board is just the
Edge TPU connected via USB-C
to whatever development system
you need, be it a Raspberry
Pi or a Linux workstation.
Now this teachable machine shows
off a form of edge training.
Now traditionally, there's
three ways to do edge training.
There's K-nearest neighbors,
weight imprinting,
and last layer retraining.
But for this demo,
we're actually
using the K-nearest
neighbors approach.
So in this animated GIF, you
can see that the TPU enables
very high classification rates.
The frame rate you
see here is actually
the rate at which the
TPU is classifying
the images that I'm showing it.
In this case, you can
see that we're getting
about 30 frames per second.
It's essentially
real-time classification.
And with that, I actually have
one of our teachable machine
demos here.
So if we can turn this on--
there we go.
OK, so on this board, we have
our Edge TPU development board
assembled with a camera
and a series of buttons.
Now each button corresponds
with a class and lights
up when the model identifies
an object from the camera.
But first we have
to plug this in.
Now every time I take
a picture, by pressing
one of these buttons, it
associates that picture
with that particular class.
And because it's running
inference on the Edge TPU,
it lights up immediately.
So once it's finished booting,
the first thing I have to do
is train it on the background.
So I'll press this blue button.
And you can see it
immediately turns on.
This is because, again, it's
doing inference in real time.
Now, if I train one of the
other buttons using something
like a tangerine,
press it a few times--
OK, so now you can see, it can
classify between this tangerine
and the background.
And further, I can even
grab other objects,
such as this TFLite sticker.
It looks very similar, right?
It's the same color.
So let's see.
What was the class I used?
Yellow, OK.
Sorry.
So now, even though
it's a similar color,
it can still discern
the TensorFlow Lite logo
from the tangerine.
Oh, sorry-- tangerine.
There you go.
[APPLAUSE]
So you can imagine, in
a manufacturing context,
your operators, with
no knowledge of machine
learning or training
in machine learning,
can adapt your system
easily and quickly
using this exact technique.
So that's about it for the demo.
But before I go, I
should grab the clicker.
And also I should say we're
also giving away some Edge TPU
accelerators.
For those of you
here today, we'll
have one available
for you as well.
And for those of you
on the live stream,
you can purchase one at
coral.withgoogle.com.
[APPLAUSE]
OK.
[MUSIC PLAYING]